detrás de las ruinas de este antiguo
colegios las granjas colectivas
soviéticas se extienden ahora 1900
hectáreas de una explotación privada
fundada por Jean me chama a mediados de
los años 90 el país se desarrolló muy
rápido y las granjas también se
desarrollaron
formado en la escuela soviética el
agricultor de 59 años ahora es dueño de
1250 bovinos
ah vale vale pues de la independencia de
Estonia en 1991 emergieron muchas
empresas nuevas pequeñas granjas pero
también compañías más grandes con
accionarios
[Música]
empleo actualmente solo tiene
contratados a 12 empleados
Jan es agricultor y también give
porque crecieron las granjas de
historias pues porque es muy complicado
utilizar tecnologías modernas en una
granja pequeña
primero es caro y hay muy pocos animales
para que sea rentable
así que con la tecnología el negocio de
la agricultura se desarrolló
inevitablemente para seguir siendo
competitivo
disminuir la pobreza erradicar la
corrupción y acabar con la burocracia
así que la agricultura no fue lo único
en modernizarse toda la sociedad Estonia
se orientó hacia las nuevas tecnologías
posible seguir haciendo las cosas de la
misma manera
materialización le permite al Estado
economizar el equivalente al 2% del PIB
y estos servicios ahora accesibles para
los extranjeros facilitan los negocios
de
la empresa
entre fabricantes y proveedores
esas personas nos han inspirado nos
ayuda nos enseñan y también invierten y
nuevas empresas emergentes la economía
de Estonia es la más desarrollada entre
las antiguas repúblicas soviéticas en
Estonia es claramente el mejor lugar del
mundo para montar una empresa emergente
o el
80% de su consumo eléctrico en su suelo
y está producción local le ha permitido
distanciarse con más rapidez de Rusia y
de Moscú
PNG color marrón a Quim es esquisto
bituminoso se parece a las páginas de un
libro viejo cuando uno lo rasca con un
cuchillo se vuelve polvo
una antigua mina fue reconvertida en
museo señal de la importancia de esta
industria Yuri sala cabo túneles durante
19 años hasta su cierre en 2001 y la
parte superior hay que sostener el techo
con vigas grandes luego hay que cavar
huecos en el muro para poner explosivos
y cuando estallan quedan montones de
piedras en el suelo con esas máquinas
recogíamos las piedras para ponerlas en
las carretillas
pero ahora las nacen los días que
llegaron a Estonia son mucho más
eficaces mucho más productivas
a pesar de los avances tecnológicos
recientes el esquisto bituminoso sigue
siendo un combustible fósil que
contamina el aire y el agua del país
Estonia considera recurrir a la energía
nuclear para mantener a toda costa su
independencia energética frente a su
vecino ruso